Here's one way to answer this question.
We have our two variable definitions.
We can print out the distance light travels in one cycle
by dividing the speed of light by cycles per second using the variables.
When we run that, we see the result is 0.11.
That's 0.11 m or 11 cm.
Another way to solve this that might be better would be to introduce another variable.
Instead of just printing the result, we can store it in a variable.
We'll call it "cycle&#95;distance".
Now when we run it, there's no result.
We haven't printed that out yet, but we've stored it in a variable.
Now we can print out the result of cycle&#95;distance,
which gives us the 0.11 m.
If we want the results in centimeters--
well, since we've already stored the result in meters in a variable,
we can compute that by just multiplying that by 100.
Now we get the result in centimeters.